[Music]
i am
seven
every day before school
i turn on the tv and watch my favorite
science show for children it is nerdy
and sciencey and marvelous there are
colors and bubbles and explosions i love
it
now one day before school
i turned on the tv
it's not playing
very weird
day two
same thing
mommy
what's happening
my mom tells me
that the show's
been moved
it now plays when i'm
in
school
why would you play a children's show
when children are in school
how dare you adults are so
stupid
my mom says chill bro chill
she says that i should write a letter to
the tv channel
she doesn't think i'd write the letter
i am angry and i write the letter we
mail it in together
now
the next week
i turn on my tv
and
like magic my show is back
now
once again
every day before school i get colors and
bubbles and explosions and my life
is once again amazing
what did i learn
as a seven-year-old
anger
ignites action
ignites
change
as a young boy however
i was always told that anger
in malay is not part of malaysian
culture
good boys
literally being soft-spoken was
synonymous with being polite
talking back was bad raising your voice
was bad
anger
was bad
yet as i grew up
there were feelings
stronger deeper and harder to suppress
injustice incited indignation unfairness
unleashed umbrage
yet growing up in a semi democracy
meant that i couldn't fully
express these feelings
in here huh
you don't talk so much you talk okay the
government will come for you you watch
out
warn my parents my teachers
adults
no wonder the government had never lost
an election
people were angry yes
but people were even more
afraid
my friends let me ask you this
when was the last time you were truly
deeply
angry
and how did you react to it did you
embrace it did you let it move you or
did you distance yourself
from this feeling
i ask you this
because in my experience at stanford and
at harvard
i've found
that america isn't so different from
malaysia after all
at business school and at public policy
school there is this reticence
this distaste
this distancing from
anger
we the learned are intellectual we're
cerebral we are above this
fury is seen as uncouth wrath shameful
anger unbecoming
outrage
undignified
now
i think this is wrong
and this is why i'm telling you a story
about
an uncouth unbecoming andrew who used
anger
to change lives in profound ways
2018
my prime minister
steals 4.5 billion dollars
from my country
the the guardian calls it the world's
largest financial scandal your
department of justice calls it the
largest kleptocracy case ever
his cronies spend our money partying
with paris hilton and leonardo dicaprio
his stepson
spends our money to fund the wolf
of wall street
that's right
these guys stole malaysian tax money to
make a movie that glorifies how wall
street stole from american investors
you cannot make this up
how
dare
you
4.5 billion dollars stolen
malaysians are livid like never before
my prime minister knows that he cannot
suppress our anger any longer so he
decides to suppress
our votes
the economist proclaims stop thief
malaysian prime minister is about to
steal an election
financial times blares malaysian
election falls prey to gerrymandering
and as if this was not enough
he decides to hold polling day
on a wednesday
mid-week
not on a week end as is our tradition
this is a blatant attempt to stop urban
voters from traveling home to their
hometowns to vote
suppressing turnout
how
dare
you
furious
my friends and i decide to act
we found a movement to mobilize votes we
call it
go back to vote in malay
we ride the pulse of a nation we harness
the anger of thousands and turn it into
real tangible action
we are an overnight success
pulang mangundi becomes the top trending
hashtag on malaysian twitter
we are
winning
and then
and then 17 000 russian bots
attack us
17 000 russian bots
one month before this the world had
learned
about cambridge
analytica we had seen how russian
disinformation swayed the results of an
american election and against this
this this backdrop of global outrage and
global questions around the future of
democracy
we
wondered what russian mods were doing
in a malaysian
election
and then
the next day our friends
in high places told us that the secret
service
was watching us
we didn't know whether this was true
or what this meant but if these threats
were true
real or perceived
were our lives and liberty
at stake
this is how they get you
intimidated half of my team
wanted to shut our platform down
like so many before us we were angry
yet we were also
afraid
so
so we sat down over zoom
we named our fears
we told our stories and we were honest
to ourselves
and we listened
intently truthfully
and yet
i
pushed i challenge my friends to close
their eyes
and remember why
we started
in the first place
remember the 4.5 billion dollars stolen
remember the midday polling week to
suppress turnout remember the
gerrymandering
together we remembered
together we seethe
and together once again
we chose
to fight
my friends
in 2018
fulang magundi directly helped 10 000
voters travel home to vote
indirectly we energize online
mobilization
helping contribute to an 82 voter
turnout
we the people
kicked out a corrupt prime
minister we the people were angry we
took action and we won
my friends i am so proud
so proud to be a small part of the first
regime change in malaysian history
so proud to help end the reign of the
longest continuously ruling party in the
democratic world
angering knights action ignites change
plato tells us
that anger can be powerful
he calls it fumos
a special type of anger a deep
dissatisfaction a spirited zeal that one
can use and harness to overcome fear to
turn inaction
into action
i see
fumos
in the global reaction to stand with
ukraine
because we must stand up to mad men
i see fumos in the 20 million americans
who march for george floyd the largest
civic movement in american history
because black lives matter
i see thumos in ex gonzalez who awakened
the consciousness of millions of
students as a survivor of the parkland
high school shooting because we call bs
i see thumbos in greta tunberg who
shamed
global leaders into climate action
because how
dare
you
my friends
there's so much injustice in this world
and sometimes the only way out
is to be still
and listen to that voice in your heart
that pinch that fire in your soul
when i am
angry
i am closer to the truth
and when i am still
and listen to this truth and let this
truth move me
i
am
powerful
anger ignites action ignites
change
so i ask you this ladies and gentlemen
what are you
angry
about
[Music]